what I'm doing is the last people that
were here it's supposed to bring some of
their own tarp spread them out use their
stuff but instead they use mine
common courtesy would dictate cleaning
them that's what I asked hey if you're
gonna use something clean it dry it put
it back away well right now it's at a
time of year where everything's frozen
they're supposed to bring some of their
own tarp spread them out use their stuff
um but instead they use mine even if I
brought them to the river it's the wrong
time of year they're not gonna dry I'm
gonna have to burn them I can't leave
this smell around all of this it all
emits an odor bear smell from ten miles
away it's a recipe for the raw fish so
whenever people leave I've got to come
through and kind of fine-tooth comb it I
mean look at all this garbage we got
blood and everything back here these are
my water barrels for winter this is what
I disinfect keep clean for myself to be
healthy and hydrated and some son of a
decided hey let's just choose up that
makes me mad it is so disrespectful but
look at this
if I came to visit you is that how I
leave your house no but it's how they
leave mine this has to go out here and
I'll have to figure out a way to clean
it disinfect it in the time where I'm
freezing up I don't have limitless
supplies of water right now who does
that I would not go to your house and do
that man good anyways what drew my eye
to it salt and blood all over my floor
so I need to get the bleach really do
ston that area a bear
Wolverine wolf I mean just take a look
around you how many times have animals
come through the sides this building is
on its last legs to me it's not fair and
it is so close for me to saying no more
hunters I'm sorry and just deal with the
people that want a camp and in
photograph shoot with the camera over a
gun I mean I hunt for the meat that I
eat but I wouldn't do this to somebody's
that the Bears come in and destroy this
you think they're all gonna go home my
bad I think I'll help you with that
hundred thousand dollar replacement
they're not spoiled I'll just bring
these back in and set them down there I
can't clean them until tomorrow anyhow